you said you used to have a mixed view
on short films what was that view
and how has it changed sure yeah so
years ago you know i kind of would hear
other creator friends talking about
filming a short film and i think that's
great you know because you're honing
your art you're
you're doing something and you can
certainly send that to film festivals
but i'm very i was very much at that
time a
creator who was trying to find out how i
was going to be making
a financial living as a filmmaker and at
that point i had
absolutely no idea how i would be making
any money on a short film
i know that there's like there are
stories out there where certainly
someone can sell a short film or they
can get green lit
um but i found that to be very few and
far between and a short film can be
really expensive it can be really time
consuming
you know et cetera et cetera but i'm so
happy to report that i've been
completely debunked
on my murky uncertainty about short
films because
thanks to kovid we aaron and i my my
creative partner
uh we have been filming short films like
two
three times a month and uh you know
putting them up on youtube and we've had
phenomenal success both
you know i wouldn't say we're like
phenomenal like
phenomenal financial success but
certainly a respectable
you know sort of youtube success um but
more so honing the craft and and when
you're working at that
frequency where we're working on a new
script putting it into production uh you
know
me even me as an actress i'm lucky
enough to be able to act in them because
you know we can't have anyone at the
apartment it's just
usually aaron and i may be one other
person who's been quarantined and tested
um you know you you get to try all these
new things and you get to i've been able
to shape myself as an actress and
uh really really work on it you know and
and you
really learn by doing and by doing these
short films at such a pace
we are learning it is it's like a master
class that we just happen to be doing at
home
and like we're we're the teachers and
the world is
i mean the world is the great the world
the world lets us know if they like the
shorts and then we take that that
feedback and we just try and keep
getting better and better
so short films two thumbs up i highly
recommend them for any
new filmmaker even i thought i was like
a seasoned filmmaker even though i
hadn't done anything you know i did
electric love
which was my first feature and i had
done one short and i'd probably done
something like a dozen music videos
which is still a decent decent little
bit of work
um but these short films i mean we're
aaron's learning lighting we're
experimenting with sound
uh production you know production design
i'm costing everything
and uh and then on top of all that the
scripts
we get to write new scripts like two or
three a month that are just these you
know three or four page scripts
and it's so much fun because if you've
ever written a feature film script
you know that's a labor of love you're
gonna be working on that baby for like
months and months possibly years you
know it depends on what your your uh
schedule is like
and then you still have probably years
to get it in production
you know depending on what that schedule
is like as well and then you know it's
kind of up to the descript
the distributor and this the sale the
final sales channel when it's going to
be seen by the world
so you've worked on something for years
and years and years all from this one
story you started telling
years ago but with short films i'm
writing you know
all these shorts a month i get to
experiment with all these different
flavors of storytelling and i'm really
i'm like a kid in a candy store now so
two thumbs up for short films if
anyone's looking or curious about short
films
i highly recommend do you think though
they've evolved
from maybe when you first started making
movies
which i know it's not like a huge amount
of time but do you think that now
shorts are more in demand
i absolutely think so i mean you know
is its own interesting year because
people seem to be consuming
content just voraciously you know
they're watching
everything all the time i feel like now
i watch more
youtube uh high production content as
well whereas i used to just be like oh
no no i'm just going to turn on netflix
or you know hulu or what have you
um but now i'll watch films all day on
youtube and love them they're high
production value they're tight they're
interesting
and i just see so much more of a market
and so much more possibility now
even youtube is being treated very
seriously by major
major creators like um a channel that i
really enjoy is kevin james's channel
he has been doing these really high
production value funny
and kind of weird short short films like
or short sketches or something
um and they're on his channel and he you
can tell that he's putting in
time to build this as if it's its own as
if it's his own tv station
you know and i love seeing huge talents
like that
take the space like a youtube channel so
seriously because i think the
the phrase youtube channel is as we
speak evolving from just
how i have a youtube channel to i've got
a
i essentially have like my own tv
station like right here
and it's a very cool thing to see the
evolution yeah
if at the start you didn't believe in
short films
why did you begin making them that it
was really all
just a test so we were going to be
making val
our our second feature together aaron
and i and
we needed to practice scaring people
and so we were like you know i i we knew
at least then but that we hadn't
made anything scary yet and we really we
hadn't made anything that was in the
horror genre so
we knew that there was some sort of art
form to scaring people
you know of course you have your jump
scares personally i actually think
there's still an art to jump scares even
though
by definition you're just um you're
you're
kind of creating some sort of either
loud auditory or loud like
shocking visual really fast to the
viewer so it kind of sounds like it's a
little bit basic but you can have so
much fun with jumpscare
i'm like tangenting on the the art of
the jump scare um
but uh the reason that we started doing
these short films
is because we were practicing for val
and so we got started
with the short film bed head which aaron
had learned how to do
this kind of cool masking trick by
watching one of our favorite creators
david sandberg
we love him he's certainly like uh you
know just a really inspiration
really inspirational person absolutely
and obviously he
got i believe his start on youtube with
lota his wife
and they they they're kind of you know
it's very much what we're doing so we
and we're like oh we're home we've got a
camera let's do it that seemed to work
for them let's just pound the pavement
and keep
going until maybe something could
similar could happen for us
um and so anyways we started testing
that and we were watching their shorts
we're like okay cool
and then we started creating our own
stories kind of jumping off from there
bed head was a super fun creepy piece
about my character it's laundry day and
i'm making my bed and
when i fling the sheet across the bed
all of a sudden the sheet falls
and there's this uh shape of sort of
like a creature
underneath the the sheet and my
character also might i add
some of my worst acting ever ever to now
live forever online
but but whatever what i thought it was a
test to people of the world i thought it
was a test
so i mean that's no excuse i should have
always been bringing my a game but maybe
i wasn't
i was a little rusty then too but
anyways my character sees this
doesn't react very much so when you
watch the short you're gonna that's why
i'm bringing it up because she's just
like
something's under the bed what could it
be you just keeps going making the bed
as if it's all fine
it's not um and so anyways my character
tries to discover what's under the bed
and eventually you know
the ending which i won't spoil happens
um and then our second
exciting foray into horror was the ice
cream man
which i just love the ice cream man is
always going to be one of my favorite
short films
because it's about this like ancient
evil
sinister entity that's taken the shape
of this ice cream
man who lives in the freezer and he's a
thousand years old and he leaves these
twisted popsicle sticks with these like
evil little riddles and you have to
follow the popsicle stick and see it
and by then it's too late because you've
already eaten his haunted ice cream it's
a whole thing
and it's very fun and it took us like
three months to make that short and
it just shows you what growth can happen
when you keep practicing at something
because now it takes us about
two maybe three nights to film in a
complete short
and it takes two days to edit and we've
got that that baby out for the world to
see
like a week later so we've really
shortened the time frame and getting our
shortstop to the world
do you post these short films only
online or do you also
submit the shorts to film festivals you
know
as of as of today we have not sent
anything to any film festivals and
that's only that's actually just partly
because
2020 felt like the entire world was
closed down
but you know maybe what we should we
should have because perhaps there would
have been
uh less competition maybe we could have
gotten into some bigger festivals you
know
we can always like take that information
and just try
there's also something to be said for
some shorts in my mind
are just for viewing entertainment and
some shorts are like
that's a film festival piece you know i
think there's like a different flavor to
them
and so i would say of the shorts we've
made maybe the ice cream man would have
been a good film festival one i think
the necklace is very stylized and
very of like exorcist was an inspiration
for for the necklace
um so i think that that would be one
that we could and we still could submit
it you know
unless their rules are you know some
some film festivals say you can't
publicly share this short it has to be
the premiere has to only be with us
so yeah perhaps maybe i will send it
over to film festivals
part of the reason i haven't is because
i also just love going to them you know
you go
and the events you're meeting the other
filmmakers and i mean without that fun
chunk to it i've kind of like forgotten
about them i hate to say
well so many of them have gone online
now yeah i mean you can still have sort
of this virtual
experience i realize it's not the same
as being a person yeah but then you
don't have to do the air
the flight either so there's a win-win
yeah that's true
when you and aaron started making these
short films what were your expectations
in the first two you know bed head in
the ice cream man
zero expectations zero like we were
literally just practicing
for the feature val um but we liked the
product we thought oh this is a really
nice looking product let's just pop it
up on youtube and
yeah that'll that'll be nice it'll be
fun to have something of our work up
there
and then while we were just kind of on
the precipice of getting into production
for val
aaron herron aaron's really good at
checking like stats and all that stuff
so he's like he had been regularly
telling me like bed head
it's up to eight thousand views now you
know he's like i'm like 8 000 views
that's nothing you know what i mean
um and but finally you know we realized
that these were going somewhere
they really were you know we're bed head
i don't know what it's at now but it's
i think easily in the hundreds of
thousands of views um
devil's door is just knocking on a
million views
diet has over two million views now it's
like
our channel has aggregated like i think
something upwards of
five million views of our just six
months of intense work like that's it
because we took a break you know we did
bed head and ice cream in at the tail
end of 2019
then we filmed val and 20 at the top of
and then it was kind of like oh these
shorts are
getting some traction so it was really
like the summer i want to say
end of june maybe july where we started
taking the channel very seriously
and making it a schedule so okay we're
going to commit to two to three shorts a
month
that means we need to be turning out
these scripts just start you know it
really became like an office and really
taking it seriously as a job um as
opposed to just kind of like a trial
and check things out test things out
when we feel like it this is now we're
on like a very
uh strict schedule that's excellent wow
and that's in how how short of time did
you get those millions of views or close
to
i mean well i wanna if it's okay with
the viewers i wanna
basically count from june until december
is
that would be like our intense time of
really trying of course ice cream man
and bed head came out in like the tail
end of the previous year
um which was helpful because it starts
like get some get some irons in the fire
maybe it got us like a few hundred
subscribers
um but from june all the way until end
of december
we grew the channel from just a few
hundred i want to say was at like 900 by
june
to today we're at something like 42 000
with like over 5 million views and so
yeah it's been like oh my goodness
that's so exciting
so yeah i mean i think more people have
seen that than like any of our
although i don't know how hulu doesn't
tell us how many people have watched
electric left so we don't know how many
people watched it but you know it's
pretty exciting that people have seen
that much of our work very cool
yeah thank you that's not easy to do
that's
really that's really cool that you have
almost two viral videos basically
yeah thank you i mean we're waiting on
like the big you know like like
viral i think can be like a scale if we
were able to get something to be in like
the tens of millions
um you know of course i'm just modeling
this off of the lights out model
lights out got something like 13 million
views in the in the span of a couple of
months
and now now yeah it's pretty cool
you